the four corners of a rectangle are
located at the points eleven comma seven
eleven comma zero two comma zero and two
comma seven
plot the four corners of the rectangle
on the coordinate plane below they have
these dots and we can actually move
these around for the four corners of our
rectangle so let's look at this first
point eleven comma seven
where will that go
well let's just remind ourselves that
the first coordinate here that is our x
coordinate that tells us how far we move
in the x direction or how far we move to
the right so our x coordinate is 11 so
we can say we can start at the origin
and move 11 to the right and then our y
coordinate is 7 which says hey we need
to move 7 up from there so 1
2 3 4
7. so notice 11 that's if you were to
just drop a line straight down you would
hit the x-axis at 11 and the
y-coordinate if you were to take a
horizontal line if you were to go
straight to the left you get to y equals
7. so this is the point 11
comma 7. all right let's do the next one
then you have 11 comma 0. so let's let
me take this point right over here so
the x coordinate is once again 11 but
the y coordinate is 0 which means we
don't move up at all in the or we don't
move up at all
one way to think about it start at the
origin
you move 11 to the right and you move 0
up so this is going to sit on the x axis
right over there 11 comma 0.
all right then we have 2 comma 0.
so x coordinate is 2
and we don't move up at all so we're
going to sit on the x axis
we move 2 to the right and 0 up or you
can think of it 0 up and 2 to the right
then we have 2 comma 7. so x coordinate
is 2 but then we want to move
x coordinates 2 that we want to move 7
up to get right over there and so you
can see the corners of a rectangle right
over here
and then they ask us what is the height
of the rectangle
well let's see if we're
we're going from y equals zero to y
equals seven so the height is seven and
you can even count it one two three four
five six seven so the height of the
rectangle is
seven and then of course i can check my
answer
and
i got it right